so it's my birthday and Brady's of
promised me a present at the
nanotechnology Center
I've been told that they need to take
one of my hairs so he's sticking the
hair down with a piece of double-sided
sticky tape that's coated with copper so
it conducts electricity he's choosing a
nice flat bit quite difficult with my
hair so Mike is now putting my hair into
a very sophisticated electron ion beam
microscope I don't think I've ever had
any my has put into a vaccine before
we're now ready to go the electrons are
starting Mike's going to draw a picture
in that yellow rectangle Oh periodic
table is it right yes even got Cap'n
it's him they're so far away the
periodic table that they're drawing is a
hundred microns long fifty high we could
get a million of those periodic tables
onto one of these post-it notes the key
thing is this green bar here mike is
irradiating it with ions of gallium at
huge speed knocking off tiny flakes of
my hair and when this green bar gets to
the end the periodic table is ready
let's see what's happened whoa
so each element we'd symbol is four
microns across the size of the periodic
table is that it's eighty nine point six
seven microns across and forty six point
three nine microns from helium the top
of helium down to the bottom of
Laurentian this is by far the smallest
periodic table that I've ever seen
obviously it's the best because it's on
my hair just think how many periodic
tables you can put on my whole head all
over each hair and all the way around be
quite a lot there's the hair on the
copper it makes now just going to zoom
in so you can see the periodic table
let's go keep going so there it is great
can I have my hair back till right the
hair still there so periodic table on
one of your hairs happy birthday from
the nervous
thank you very much it's the best
present I've had actually only had two
presents today so but this one's the
nicer so we're back in chemistry there's
the biggest periodic table in Nottingham
here's the smallest who knows that's the
smallest in the world